Yeah,
I've seen,
you know,
there's a,
there's a guy online that has,
I'm on Instagram gt 500 super swap.
He took uh,
an old,
uh,
gt 500 body and put it on a gt 500 from a modern chassis and piece it together
like that.
But I was always thinking with a,
with a setup like that,
you probably can't have air bags,
right?
You can,
here's actually ways to add it into there,
but you get into the air.
It is,
yeah.
You get into the geometry and the direction of the airbag,
so beautiful that it looks so,
yeah.
But you don't want to play with the R and d of trying to put an airbag in the,
something like that unless you really,
really know what you're doing because you don't,
you know,
refraction of an inch off of,
of being where it needs to be that airbag could do more damage than good.
It's weird though because you're dealing with a totally different size body too.
So I wonder how he's doing this.
It's easy as,
it doesn't sound easy,
but it is,
is it really?
Have you done that before?
We haven't,
but I,
I understand the process and really it's just cut massage,
move in,
move out.
You know,
because there's a company called Mag Motors.
You ever heard of them?
I don't think I have.
Go to a MAG motors.com they have a,
what they're doing is they're putting a carbon fiber body on a modern gt 500 but
they're using a 67 like Eleanor body,
but they're making it out of carbon fiber.
So it's a,
that one's gross.
Go to the silver one.
That white one looks best to hate the Eleanor bodies,
so you really know overplayed.
How dare you.
It's just too,
it's just been done so many times,
but who cares?
It's amazing.
Yeah,
go.
that's,
those are the images,
but go to get it from the side so you get a better look at it.
That's fucking beautiful car.
See,
to me it sits weird.
It looks like it sits a little too high and it looks like they're worried,
like I don't know anything about them.
But to me looking at it,
it's like you need to get it down a little bit and get a little more attitude to
get a deeper dish on the wheel.
Um,
well I think what they're doing is trying to use all the geometry yes.
Of the modern car.
Correct.
So you end up with something,
it looks like it could go four wheeling
a little bit.
Right?
Yeah,
it's not,
it's definitely not slammed.
Yeah.
In terms of looks right.
Yes.
I mean,
I'm sure the car runs and drives and performed unbelievably,
but it's missing a little to me it's missing little something.
Um,
you know that company classic recreation's [inaudible] have you seen them?
No,
I don't think so.
They do.
They're doing similar cars like that too,
but they're doing it,
you know,
from the ground up.
There's a lot of people doing it.
Um,
because it's with technology coming the way that it has,
it's,
it's not as hard and to do as it used to be.
Um,
it's still tea labors tasks,
don't get me wrong,
but you know,
you can make all those systems work in anything.
I see a guy like you that's a car guy.
You look at an Eleanor and you look at it like it's played,
but a person who doesn't see them all the time.
It was not in a industry.
You,
when was the last time you saw one of those fucking things on the street?
Shit,
I ain't never said Jackson.
There was like five of them for sale.
That's the thing.
If you go there,
but like fusion motor sports,
there are down the street here they make,
they're the only licensed dealers.
They have some deal with the,
the woman who was the,
she was the wife of the guy who wrote gone in 60 seconds or producing or
something like that.
And so they make a c go to fusion.
Eleanor.
They make some pretty sick ones.
But you think there's a played out personally?
Yeah.
I'm just not an in our car fan.
That is fucking beautiful.
Why do you hate America,
Richard?
I don't hate America.
How could you,
how could you not love that?
It's just,
there's hundreds if not thousands of them out there.
Come on Bro.
You must hate America.
No Way.
Secretly.
And I love the mustangs.
I've got three of them,
myself included,
a real 68 Shelby.
But uh,
um,
is it the shape or the color scheme?
I think it's this shape.
I mean,
to me it's,
it's such a popular car in the movie that you know,
too many people did it and now everybody's doing it and,
and that's what I have.
Yeah.
But I mean,
how many of them are out there in comparison to like say a modern Zr One?
There's probably nearly as many of those out there.
Thousands of those.
Oh yeah.
Really?
Yeah.
There's different companies making tons of them.
All car people say that they say two cars that they think are played out,
69 Camaro's and these things,
like everybody does a 69 Camaro and everybody does Eleanor.
Yeah.
And the uh,
the Dukes of Hazzard car.
Oh yeah.
Same thing.
Yeah.
You know,
now a badass 69 charger,
don't get me wrong,
but painted orange with a flag on top that's played out.
You can't do that anymore.
That flag.
It's fucking persona non grata for sure.
You believe they pulled that show off the air?
Did Cousin yes cause the flag that shows off the air,
but it showed on like some weird obscure cable.
Jane pulled it off a TV land.
That's silly TV land.
I wrote a whole thing about it on Instagram.
How ridiculous it was.